what if we told you that the most
powerful laboratory in the world doesn't
have any microscopes safety goggles or
walls when it comes to figuring out
efficient solutions no human lab can
compete with nature
that's because evolution and natural
selection work like an experiment as
nature's conditions change designs can
either succeed or fail nature is such a
powerful lab because it can run millions
of these evolutionary experiments
simultaneously and just like lab
Nature has a lot to teach us studying
nature to create new technologies for
humans is called biologically inspired
engineering and it's been going on for
hundreds of years
when we already know something words
engineering can perfect and expanded
based on known scientific laws but when
were thinking of something new we often
need a place to start that's why
scientists observe nature to find
solutions who would've thought of alone
imagine if humans had never seen an
animal flying could engineering have led
us to the skies the first humans to
attempt flight tried to copy bird's
bodies exactly in the year 1010 for
example almost being Oliver of
Malmesbury
built a pair of human sized wings and
jumped off his Abby whistle but he fell
almost immediately and broke both of his
legs
Oliver strategy didn't work because they
copied the birds exactly as you solve it
or pixel by pixel instead of trying to
understand the basic principles of
flight almost a thousand years later the
Wright brothers still studied birds for
inspiration but they didn't copy Birds
pixel by pixel instead they use
principle based engineering to apply
their observations in a way that humans
can actually use and today although our
helicopters and spacecraft don't look
much like birds at all we are able to
make them fly because we understand how
to apply basic principles to new
situations
let's take a break from the sky and
visit the bottom of the ocean to check
out a class sponge called the Venus
flower basket
this sponge uses a network of hairlike
fibers called spicules to hold itself
still in the soft ocean floor each
spicule has a solid core and circled by
cylinders that get thinner as you move
farther from the center now you can't
ask nature why it does what it does but
the unusual geometric pattern of
cylinders and the spicules made a
research team suspect that this design
had a purpose for the glass sponge
possibly to help make it strong we can't
just start making technology that
imitates stick you little by pixel first
we have to make sure that this natural
design is really a source of strength to
do that the researcher set up a
theoretical model that works with
physics principles they use the model to
predict the strong as possible being
designed using cylindrical layers now
the model could have come up with
anything small layers the big ones big
thick layers or even one giant layer
which is a way most things are designed
already but the strongest layer design
looks exactly like the stick you'll
which means the spicule shape must have
at least something to do with strength
also a strength is important to the
sponge it might have even more physical
features that make it strong and that we
can study to engineer stronger
structures so now that we know the
spicule design is strong what can we do
with it here's an example engineers have
been able to manufacture strong
materials like steel but they're often
not very cheap or environmentally
friendly if we can make a lightweight
layer beam out of say wood that's just
as strong as a uniform steel beam
imagine the environmental and economic
benefits what other secrets to
innovation and efficiency might be
flying over our heads or hiding below
the surface we'll have to keep looking
to find out and while we look make sure
we understand the scientific principles
that drive our natural experiments
[Music]